[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
uh chris sims pro football talk live
co-host
and the former nfl quarterback give me
this strategy last night you did not
like
well the strategy i did not like
well i mean i i think the 49ers pick at
number three
is probably the strategy i did not like
okay that would be the first one okay
let me start let me start there because
you're you're friends with kyle shanahan
right
right right you've known him for 20
years 20 years
right uh and i i thought you kept saying
mac jones
and i okay there has to be some kind of
contact between you two
and then i realized that maybe you don't
have a strong friendship with kyle
shanahan anymore i think that's really
what it is
uh but they they spent a lot to go up
and get trey lance
and uh was mac jones's smoke screen all
along
i mean listen i don't know that i don't
know and again i talked to my buddy kyle
shanahan we talk about a lot of football
as i've always explained to people we
don't get into the specifics of
their football team they don't i don't
so i don't know
now i could just say this like i had
conversations after the college year was
over and everything like that
i know he viewed mac jones as a very big
time
prospect for sure but no i was going off
of
what i thought i knew of my friend and
the kind of quarterback he likes
he's always waxed poetically about drew
brees
and matt ryan and those type of
quarterbacks to where i thought
all right mac jones is drew brees to me
coming out
and i thought that's where he would go
so uh maybe we're not as good a good of
friends as i thought or maybe i don't
know him as well as i did but
no i one don't know if i ever would have
traded up i i've said that from the
start i would have never traded up to
three in this draft anyways once i knew
i wasn't gonna get trevor lawrence or
zack wilson
and i think that the number three pick
in trey lance is
very very risky all right if i said you
could have mac jones justin fields or
trey lance
i'm taking mac jones i am i'm okay i am
i'm definitely did the patriots get his
steel
yes i think i mean you saw how bill
acted i mean
they were on the clock for what seven
seconds and they turned the clock they
turned it in
so they obviously you know
thought that he is a guy that really
knows how to play the position and play
it the way they want to and really again
in that in my heart of hearts
that's where you know i still i i got to
see it to believe it or hear so that i
really still think the 49ers traded up
for mac jones originally
and somewhere in that process it got
changed
you know i think a lot of people in the
nfl thought the carolina panthers
and the new england patriots were hot on
mac jones
and i think that's why shanahan moved up
i don't know that
but that's what i do believe in my heart
of hearts and as you could tell i've
been wrong in that before anyways
the strategy you liked last night
how could you not love the new york
giants and what they did
right i think that's one you know dave
gettleman he gets a lot of crap i'm a
giants fan
but once you see okay devonte smith who
it sounds like they really had their eye
on he's gone
to trade down and get a first round pick
for
next year and then also get
a guy who's a tyree kill type of weapon
in cadarius tony
so they kind of get a guy that they
needed or wanted anyways
and yet they get a first round pick out
of it it's hard for me not to like that
move by the new york giants
jimmy garoppolo's future in san
francisco is
what over over they can say what they
want
but like so here's the other thing i
don't know this is where it's dicey with
that pick right and i don't love this
strategy
trey lance you've heard me say i don't
love his throwing motion
i don't think he's the most natural
thrower in the in the draft by any
stretch of the imagination
i think his running is good but i think
it's overrated again it's against one
double a people it's not lamar jackson
we're talking about
all right so that's where i question it
he's never run a two-minute drill
in his college career he's never really
had a game where
he had her like the pressure was on you
to perform at a high level for them to
win the game and he didn't play football
last year
you can't sit him out again another year
behind jimmy garoppolo at some point the
guy's got to play and throw footballs
if you want to get him better at it so i
think ultimately they could say what
they want but
jimmy g i would think is on the trade
block as soon as they feel like
okay trey lance he's comfortable here
he knows our offense and that's maybe
when you hear that
talk but you do you think the niners
start the season with jimmy garoppolo
i don't okay i don't i don't i don't i
don't think i think to me there you're
you're getting into risky territory once
again they got a good football team
you know oh so when are they gonna make
the change after they're nine and two
or maybe in the playoffs and like what
if they go to the nfc championship game
and they're like a 13-3 team
and now you got jimmy garoppolo as your
starter all year you traded all those
picks to what what are you going to do
with trey lance now
so that's where i think you you got to
play him he needs it
and the beauty of the pick at least to
say this because i know i've said more
negative than positive here
shanahan is a genius in the run scheme
and now to have a quarterback like this
go along with it
that's where i think there is beauty to
the pick and could be really really
intriguing going forward
yeah it gives him sort of that lamar
jackson option he's not
lamar jackson but it does open things up
a little bit more
the bengals at five i thought the smart
move was
getting a tackle to protect your
quarterback instead of a wide receiver
for your quarterback because your
quarterback is not useful if he's on his
back
uh it's a it's a tough one yeah i i
think
i think chase is wonderful right but
i still have to protect my quarterback
and and you saw the kansas city chiefs
realize as great as mahomes is if we
don't protect him
then you know he he becomes mortal yeah
right no i i it was a tough decision for
for my money
i mean sewell is a special tackle you're
right they haven't been good up front
they haven't opened up holes for joe
mixon they play in the afc north that's
got studs galore coming off the edge
so it makes sense but i also understand
the pick like like you said
chase is special i mean he was the best
college wide receiver
two years ago now it's hard for me to
think what the kind of athlete and
specimen he is that he wouldn't have
still had that title
if he had played this past year so i
think from that standpoint there's a
special connection with your quarterback
and you know they're going the version
of like hey we're going to get tyree
kill and sammy watkins and receivers
first
and then they're gonna try to fill in
the offensive line to your point and
there should be some really good ones
there
for them to take advantage of at the top
of the second
even the top of the third the the
offensive line
is is a pretty deep position in this
draft did the bears get a steal
i don't know if they got a steal i mean
it's got the potential to be a steal
you know fields is dicey for me i know
i'm in the minority with that i think
i've told you a little bit i have a
little issue with how he does throw the
ball i think there's a
little hitch in his giddy up there's
some mechanical things that really
concern me
that i'm not sold you can definitely fix
but
his arm is powerful and his run running
is special
there's no doubt he was the best running
quarterback in this draft
he's cam newton except i would say he's
quicker than cam newton coming out of
college and that stuff so
that's where of course i they can maybe
buy them some time
and you can use that aspect as he
continues to get polished and better
with some of the throwing aspects of his
game
chris sims pro football talk live
co-host
what do you do if you're the green bay
packers with aaron rodgers
i mean the writing's on the wall
don't you think i mean but but who wrote
it
they did when they chucked jordan love
they wrote it on the wall now they're
trying to like
you know cross it out with like some
pencils and like be like no we didn't do
it it's not really real and like they're
trying to cover up for it but
for me that's where it starts you know
and
i think rogers will be back this year
but i think this is what i've been
saying for the last two weeks i think
this is it though
i don't think you'll ever see him in
green bay after this season
um there's there's issues there and i do
think the broncos would be the team
why not just trade him now i don't know
you're right
i don't know you know one
because the guy they drafted in the
first round is not
ready yet so that's the first problem
and then two he's still
definitely one of the three best players
in football and aaron rodgers
and their team is good so they're gonna
try to exhaust all options to try to
save that because
they are in a super bowl window but
they've you know they've blown
it a lot by not really supporting the
guy to to take advantage of that window
opportunity
i have no information on this but i got
the feeling here's my theory that rogers
said to the packers yesterday hey you
jacked up my draft yesterday or last
year by taking jordan love
didn't even give me a heads up now i'm
gonna jack up your draft day here
and now the game is on i i i mean i
don't
i don't like put that past him a little
bit you know i think the the jumping off
point of course
was the 49ers calling green bay and
taking one more shot
and seeing if that can happen you know
there's no doubt
so uh i do think for the first time in
his
career public perception is on his side
a little bit here
just because i think everybody
recognizes how good he is he's never
really had those game-changing
difference makers around him the
pressure's always been on him
and the packers made this bed so it's
really just to be like how
serious is he gonna go all in on this
and really try to force
green bay's hand uh is he willing to
kind of put himself
out there is gonna be the big question
for me okay where could you see him land
like the the broncos are the team like i
said that i think make a lot of sense
you know i i had heard that they were
kind of hot on him for maybe the idea of
being the quarterback in 2022
uh before this whole conversation
started anyways
and you know a lot like when peyton
manning went to denver
there's a lot of things here that are
similar like whoa there's sneaky
talent at that wide receiver position
they got studs there they got a stud
tight end
they've got their offensive line in
order finally and their defense with vic
fangio and von miller and chubb and
you know now patrick certain and kyle
fuller and ronald darby
i mean they're they're one of those
teams that i do think could jump on the
scene this year if they get the right
quarterback play where we go
whoa they're more of a contender than
than i expected
give me the quarterback who will be
taken tonight
that will eventually be a starter i
think that's kellan monde
i i've always thought kellan monde had
the ability to be a first round
quarterback
he's got everything you want he's been
playing pro football at texas a m the
last few years and what i mean that is
playing in the pocket with pressure
around him and having to throw
into extremely tight windows and make
high level throws
he passes it with great grades all the
time
explosive arm really good athlete
unbelievable technique if he would just
be a little bit more loose
and play backyard football dan he would
have been a first-round pick i mean i
don't i don't doubt that but
explain that explain that what do you
mean he's a little
a little robotic in the pocket you know
jimbo fisher is very much like no you
stand in the pocket and go
one two three and there's plays where
you watch and you go
wait one and two aren't open and the
pockets kind of collapse and you're too
fast and athletic get out
buy some time you know be a zack wilson
or trevor lawrence and get out and now
try to find a throw down the field that
way
that's like an area he needs to get
better at but that's one that doesn't
concern me a whole lot that's an easier
fix to me than
fixing justin fields mechanical issues
and things like that
give us some other names to uh keep an
eye on tonight
well jeremiah wusu coramoa
i love i i loved watching him i i saw a
few games with him and i thought he was
an impactful player
i just don't know at that position
that's why he didn't get drafted in the
first round
i think so again i think your logic is
right i think he's kind of one of those
hybrid guys where everybody's like
man we like him but is he going to be a
safety or a linebacker
what what exactly he's going to get is
he going to do and i think that scares
people i think people are scared of that
kind of formula i think they've gotten
back to like
the uh we don't love the isaiah simmon
things all that much
we'd rather just get a guy that we know
is really good at this one spot
uh but i think you look at him uh deami
brown from north carolina to watch out
for
i said mon elijah moore the wide
receiver from
ole miss terrace marshall jr the wide
receiver
for lsu i think you see him go off here
pretty good
aziz ojolari the edge guy from georgia i
think those are the few of the names
that jump
out to me that you see go off in the top
15 20 picks of this round dan
thank you bud we'll be following you on
twitter chris sims pro football talk
live co-host thank you have a great
weekend
you too buddy